par ailleurs françois bayrou était
l'invité de jean-pierre elkabbach ce
matin le patron du modem a une nouvelle
fois reconnu qu'il n'avait pas forcément
mené la meilleure des campagnes
comparant même son algarade avec daniel
cohn bendit sur le plateau de france 2
au coup de tête donné par zidane à
materazzi en finale de la coupe du monde
en 2006
vous savez en finale de la coupe du
monde zidane donne un coup de tête et ça
arrive à des orgies dan est un type en
fait un homme qui je crois n'est garde
ses nerfs en général ils arrivent qui
est des moments où voilà tout simplement
s'exprime quelque chose qui devrait
naturellement être gardé conservé pour
joint au frigo et puis tout d'un coup
explose parce qu'à un moment est devenu
un moment insupportable à cran